[Musique]
une profession qui n'a jamais démérité
qui a 200 morts dans ses rangs
à cause du coût vide qui est la
profession qui a payé le plus lourd
tribut
et c'est des gens assis sur leur cul le
cul dans le velours les pieds sur la
moquette à la dgs c'est oui vous allez
démissionner non je vois cette réaction
épidermique de mes confrères comme un
signe d'engagement d'énergie pour la
vaccination et je ne peux que m'en
féliciter
nous allons engager un plan de relance
de l'investissement dans la santé en
france
ce plan sera dotée mesdames et messieurs
de 10,9 milliards d'euros sur les dix
prochaines années pour relancer leur
économie les états unis voient grand
1600 milliards d'euros dettes publiques
un plan massif principalement destinée
aux foyers américains
première mesure immédiate un chèque
jusqu'à 1200 euros distribués sous
conditions de ressources
ils seront des millions à le toucher ils
devront attendre la fin du mois pour se
balader librement sur leurs digues les
samedis et dimanches pour toute
l'agglomération de dunkerque trois
week-ends de confinement supplémentaires
viennent d'être annoncées par la
préfecture le confinement de l'île de
france n'est pas d'actualité parce que
cette mesure de dernier recours serait
proposé au gouvernement et au chef de
l'état si nous avions l'impression que
l'hôpital ne pouvait pas tenir
comment je vous appelle ce soir monsieur
le président françois hollande a appelé
mois françois françois je vous
appellerai etienne où samuel puisque
tienne c'est bon de famille il faudra le
moment venu c'est-à-dire quand la
croissance sera de retour
rétablir des finances pic pourquoi mais
tout simplement pour reconstituer des
réserves financières
si d'ici 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans il devait y
avoir une nouvelle pandémie
pour être en mesure d'y faire face
macron
consulte souvent nicolas sarkozy et vous
non les moindres on est peut-être que
c'est plus facile avec celui qui a été
votre très lointain prédécesseur qu'avec
votre ancien employeur
et vous dites que l'islamo gauchisme
salies aujourd'hui avec une forme de
féminisme avec le mouvement des
colonials tout cela s'agrègent avec
l'écoféminisme et le mouvement des
colonies c'est quoi les prophétisme suis
absolument scandalisé évidemment de ce
qui s'est passé
allier paix de grenoble il m'apparaît
que les méthodes qui sont utilisées par
les islamo gauchistes sont des méthodes
de mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
la domination patriarcale et blanche de
la nature est la même et de la même de
la memo si je puis dire que la
domination des femmes et qu'on ne peut
pas être écologiste sans être féministe
et qu'on peut pas être féministe sans
être écologiste domination des animaux
de la nature et des femmes c'est la même
et c'est le patriarcat blanc si ça n'est
pas une infraction pénale il peut aller
voir le doyen de l'université où le
président de l'université mais en aucun
cas eux affiché des noms des visages sur
des murs wanted ça n'est pas dans notre
culture et ce ne doit pas le devenir le
plus grand regret c'est ne pas m'être
représente une certaine façon là
aujourd'hui vous dites oui parce que je
veux quand j'ai pris cette décision j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi et il y avait des
raisons d'apprendre mais je les prises
trop tôt haaliche avait 14 ans son corps
a été repêché hier soir dans la seine
tout près de ce viaduc sur sa tête et
son visage des traces de coups les deux
suspects un adolescent de 15 ans et sa
petite amie du même âge ont été arrêtés
cette nuit à 2 heures du matin chez un
ami à argenteuil à bord d'un vol de la
compagnie tarco aviation 30 minutes
après le décollage de khartoum achats a
surgi dans le cockpit est attaqué le
pilote par surprise l'équipage a réussi
tant bien que mal à maîtriser l'animal
nous dit on mais par mesure de sécurité
l'avion a fait demi tour et un drame sur
fond de rivalité amoureuse qui s'est
nouée derrière les murs de ce lycée
professionnel privé après avoir eu une
aventure avec le suspect halliche a
semblé faire l'objet de harcèlements
puisque union de la gauche pour les
présidentielles est envisageable
françois hollande soyons lucides non